our doubt Islam is something rational
logical and if you look into it you put
this blind hatred as racism this
animosity that you might have that's
really based on a false fear but like he
did he really looked into Islam he
looked at the evidence of it it's pure
message of monotheism it's called to do
good to live a righteous life doesn't
call you to blow yourself up or anybody
doesn't call you to terrorism and all
this other all these other things that
are associated with it and with all the
negative propaganda it still continues
to be the fastest growing way of life in
the world why is that why is that you
got to ask yourself so you learned that
you know once he saw the similarities he
saw that Islam submission to the will of
the Creator not the creation that he saw
calls Muslims to believe in Moses
Abraham Jesus the last the final
minister Pro Muhammad peace be upon him
and you can put it all together from the
beginning that they didn't come with
different religions they all came with
the same simple message the same way of
life that you submit yourself entirely
to the one who created you
you don't worship a man a woman a stick
a stone a bone no Jesus peace be upon
him we love and revere he never it's a
lie if you've been taught that you've
been brought up to believe that he's God
a literal son of God this is a blatant
lie he never why is it a lie because
jesus never ever called people to
worship himself he was sent by God with
a message from God calling the people to
worship God don't make it out to be
something and isn't and don't put words
in his mouth because Jesus peace be upon
him he was subordinate to God he
worshiped God he prayed to God he ate
food and went to the bathroom he wasn't
God and he wasn't a literal son of God
he was a mighty Messenger of God and if
you can understand because this is the
crossroads this is where we go to the
right and other people they end up going
in a direction that's not based on any
proof or evidence just blind following
and this gentleman here who was with us
he wasn't about to do any blind
following he looked at all the evidence
he scrutinized it and he saw that Islam
provided Islam remember it's just an
every chord every submission to the will
of God and Jesus he didn't speak English
he spoke Aramaic
which is a sister language to Arabic and
he called on Allah ha the Creator God
Almighty Allah so look too much to
mention in this short amount of time but
Islam is simply a way of life that calls
you to have a relationship a loving
relationship with the one who created
you the one who made you the one you're
gonna return back to so call on the one
the one who will never let you down and
we believe he's the most just and loving
and he wouldn't leave you without
guidance and you asked so ask the one
who made you for guidance and continued
to tune into the deen shield this life
is short you got to figure it out what's
the purpose of light what's the meaning
of life why have I been created why am I
here just to accumulate a lot of wealth
and money party and I know there's more
to life think about it
think about it follow us subscribe to
the Deen show and as you can see I get
really excited talking about Islam
because it makes sense it really makes
sense it'll make sense to you if you
just look into it put this blind hatred
animosity or you picked up maybe through
the media of Fox News or many of these
other outlets and tune into the D show
every week so you can learn more you can
be enlightened that's right and a whole
new world will open up we'll see you
next time
inshallah God willing until that peace
be with you please subscribe to the
video follow us on our official Facebook
and Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below